seven coronavirus cases are rising as we
mentioned earlier but millions of people
are still traveling for thanksgiving
this despite pleas from most health
officials to stay home
we have kate mccarron live over at
mccarran airport with a look at how
staff are trying to keep all the
travelers safe kate good morning
yes good morning to you john mccarron is
limiting the amount of people that are
allowed inside the building for holiday
travel they are asking that only
ticketed passengers
go inside at this time aaa nevada
anticipates a 10 percent
drop in travel nationwide with that said
the tsa screened more than 3 million
people over the weekend
sunday was actually the busiest day at
airport checkpoint since early march
overall aaa expects up to 50 million
americans to travel this year
a majority of which will be driving that
number may be lower though
as more restrictions and guidelines are
put in place
they're taking a wait and see approach
you know in many areas
restrictions and things are changing
even here in nevada
with the governor asking residents to
stay home in california there's also a
travel advisory there
aaa nevada says las vegas is one of the
top hotel destinations on the west coast
for thanksgiving
if you're planning to travel outside the
city though aaa suggests checking with
state or local authorities for any new
safety restrictions
that may be in place and this afternoon
is actually going to be one of the
busiest
travel days on the roadways back here at
mccarran they do say that some of these
safety protocols could extend wait times
so they do recommend that you get here
early if possible reporting live from
mccarran airport this morning kate
houston 8 news now